Selena Gomez and the weekends romance  heats up abroad  léna and the weekend jetted off to  Florence Italy over the weekend and were  spotted getting pretty close while  taking in the sights at the piazza  michelangelo on saturday evening and i  witness tells ichi they looked very much  in love while stopping to kiss and take  pics selena looked gorgeous dressed down  in a red sweatshirt high-waisted jeans  and heels while the star boys singer  looked casual cool in a jean jacket and  black pants he paired with white  sneakers and a white hat can't keep my  hands to myself clearly neither can the  pair went on to have dinner at a nearby  restaurant where the eyewitness says  quote it was like no one else existed  just the two of them they were  completely immersed in one another  [Music]  you